[Music]
hey everyone welcome to their
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video were going to be discussing
the Death Eaters Severus Snape and
murder born in the year 1962 a muggle
father and witch mother neighbors began
attending Hogwarts in 1971 along with
Harry's mother Lily Snape was sorted
into Slytherin while Lily was sorted
into Gryffindor and this was very hard
on Snape as he was in love with Lily at
a young age Snape began practicing the
dark arts fueled by rage stemming from
incessant bullying at the hands of James
Potter Remus Lupin and Sirius Black this
led him down a dark path and sleep ended
up joining the Death Eaters along with
other sovereigns from his year Snape was
a true Death Eater quite a while before
eventually joining two good guys and
acting as a double agent while acting as
a double agent during the Wizarding war
Snape amazingly managed to stop
Voldemort from reading his mind in the
Civil had Snape to trick Voldemort and
the Death Eaters
into thinking that his allegiance was
with them this was an example of his
extreme aptitude in ah clemency in his
youth simple was a very promising young
wizard and while learning his primary
course material at Hogwarts was scribble
in his notebook
and even curses charms and potions Snape
even produces his own version of the
potions class textbook under the alias
the half-blood Prince which in addition
to the regular textbook content contains
shortcuts to creating potions as well as
spells that Snape himself had created
some were more vicious than others
particularly Sectumsempra which is a
vicious dark curse that acts like an
invisible sword causing lacerations
hemorrhaging and cuts upon its target
often after being struck the target will
lay there motionless as they lose blood
you'd be a great choice of spell for
someone wishing to commit murder which
is the topic of this video those names
allegiance later changed and while Snape
had proved himself to be an invaluable
Ally it cannot be completely ignored
that for time Snape was a full-fledged
Death Eater I don't think that Snape was
a Death Eater because he was hell-bent
on power or wished to inflict harm upon
people it was simply because he had
nowhere else to go he was extremely
talented and with the Death Eaters who
was praised for his magical knowledge it
was someone that he could belong
even if only for a little while
additionally Snape experimented with all
forms of magic and didn't afford the
dark arts like other witches and wizards
would the following excerpt from the
copper to fire discusses named initial
attraction to the dark arts Snape's
always been fascinated by the dark arts
he was famous for it at school slimy
oily greasy head kid he was serious
added and Harry and Ron grinned at each
other
Snape knew more curses when he arrived
at school than half the kids in seventh
year and he was part of a gang of
Sutherlands who nearly all turned out to
be Death Eaters and the following
passage from the Deathly Hallows further
outlined Snape's affinity with the dark
arts finding humor where Lily Evans
clearly did not thought we were supposed
to be friends
Snape was saying best friends we are
safe but I don't like some of the people
you hang around with I'm sorry but I
detest Avery and Massimo massively
what do you see him in himself he's
creepy do you know what he tried to do
to Mary McDonald day of the day Lily had
reached a pillar and leaned against it
looking up into the thin sallow face
that was nothing said Snape it was a
laugh that's all it was dark magic and
if you think that's funny
it was by hanging out with people like
malsu and Avery that sneak further
distance himself from Lily as outlined
in the following interview with JK
Rowling the interviewer asks Lily
detested Mesaba and Avery is Snape
really loved her
why didn't he sacrifice their company
for her sake - which Rowling responds
well that his name's tragedy given his
time over again he would not have become
a Death Eater but like many insecure
vulnerable people at Wormtail he craved
membership of something big and powerful
something impressive he wanted lily and
he wanted muscle Batu he never really
understood Lily's aversion he was so
blinded by his attraction to the dark
side he thought she would find him
impressive if he became a real Death
Eater
so Snape had a true pull to the dark
side for a while and it's not
unreasonable for us to wonder all sort
of dark things did Snape do did he kill
anyone torture anyone he was certainly a
Death Eater for long enough to have had
the opportunity I believe that the
following exchange between Dumbledore
and Snape indicates that he never
actually directly committed an act of
murder if you don't mind dying
said Snape roughly why not let Draco do
it that boy's soul is not yet so damaged
so
model I would not have it ripped apart
on my account and my soul Talmud or mine
what this tells us is that snape is
concerned for his own untarnished soul
if Snape had truly led a dark path where
murder had become common for him then
his soul would already be badly damaged
the reason that Dumbledore once Snape to
kill him and not Draco is to protect
trick of soul if Snape had ever
experienced or performed something akin
to murder then this would not be of any
concern to him so I believe that this
pretty convincingly suggests that Snape
with over Death Eater for many years
never committed an act of murder sure he
may have been involved with or present
when another of the Death Eaters
performed the act but he himself had not
at times it sure seemed like Snape would
have been capable of it but I just can't
see how Snape could be so genuinely
concerned for his own soul if he had
done it before and that's it for this
video what do you guys think did Snape
commit direct murder as a Death Eater
let me know down in the comments section
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]